what is the solution to all of this well
it's a lot of the stuff that obviously
Jordan Peterson talks about it's some of
the stuff that I've been showing you
that Andrew Tate's been talking about
it's some of the things that I've been
trying to talk about here just like
kind of get your roughly together
and see what you can do with the world
like that pretty much sums it up uh but
Patrick Bet David from valutainment he
had a nice little Soliloquy on why
victimhood mentality is not attractive
all of us tend to go there sometimes
well man I've been working so hard
lately you chose to be a CEO let me tell
you all this pressure just stop you had
kids nobody told you to have unprotected
sex let me tell you you know how life is
being a single man you chose to become
single nothing is attractive about
victimhood mentality it's got nothing to
do with Left Right middle Center black
white asian Middle Eastern women men gay
straight no one cares stop being a
victim it's not attractive
that is literally it but if the
Democrats did not have
however we don't know how many people it
is but they still win elections one way
or another if if a certain amount of
people in this country had not been so
brainwashed to be NPCs and just to have
no drive to do anything other than burn
everything down man we still have it so
good and that is the challenge for all
of us to find that goodness to find the
good people and go out there and and
build things I want to go with one other
thing that Patrick David said this was a
tweet that he put out yesterday that I
thought also kind of caught this really
nicely uh Alphas find each other bitter
bitter people find each other entitled
people find each other positive people
find each other big thinkers find each
other those who blame the find each
other critical thinkers find each other
those who can reason find each other
criminals find each other party animals
find each other Gamers find each other
those who believe in God find each other
atheists find each other there
complainers find each other your circle
is a direct reflection of you you
attract who you relate to I like my
circle to be driven competitive able to
reason fun loyal supportive while
constantly in the hunt for the next
Milestone if you don't like your circle
start by changing your mindset then
identify which types of people you want
in your circle eventually your circle
will upgrade
well ladies and gentlemen that is our
show for today I think that you uh are
in my circle I hope you consider me
someone that's in your circle even if
not in real life we do it through these
electronic wires and I think we are in
on this thing together and we as I
always say we got a chance to fix it
[Music]